(mumbling)
- If you guys were following
along on the vlog yesterday,
fucking Bobby Babin, lemme see this.
Fucking knew it, Bobby Babin.
- You just kinda go with the...
- Oh, with what?
Oh.
I literally said,
Bobby's like, "No,
there's nothing in there."
I'm like there's something in there.
I'm like if I just get to the
office and use a paperclip.
Fucking Babin.
Show him, Babin.
There you go, that's
what's ruining your career.
(mellow music)
(dinging)
You know I think reputation
is based on truth.
And so in today's world where
there's nowhere to hide,
instead of hiring a PR person in 1994 and
getting the right articles,
I think it's just delivering,
crush it for your employees,
crush it for your clients,
and fundamentally give
without expectation.
Go give a keynote at a
college with no expectation.
Answer those 10 emails of
people reaching out to you
that have nothing to offer you
and just give, because
they actually may have
a ton to offer you.
What I love is that reputation is becoming
a more transparent game,
and so the only way
to build a reputation is
to do the right things.
So over deliver for the
ones that have something
or the ones that don't have something.
Way too many entrepreneurs
are way too calculated
about what's in it for me.
If you can reverse that and think about
what's in it for them, you'll find out
that a lot of things are in it for you.
You guys understand that you're sitting in
the room of greatness and this will be
studied for decades to come.
You'll be an old grandma, you'll be like,
"Yes, and then I colored
my hair all sorts of colors
"one day, and then he was
recording that thing."
Facebook good morning.
Kendall, big ups to you.
Tyler, less ups for you.
Just wanna tell everybody,
is today Wednesday?
This whole hump day
thing is such bullshit.
Like hump day, like, oh
we're gonna get over the hump
and it's gonna get awesome
because the weekend
is what you have to escape a day too.
Love a day that means that
you're almost to the weekend.
Makes no fucking sense.
64% of your life is spent on working.
Do something about it if you hate it.
Fuck hump day, love every day.
So hey, I just wanna give a big shout out
to all the artists that,
and there's some more,
can you get them all, can
you get some of them, Tyler?
Big shout out to all the artists that make
portraits of me, it is
ridiculously humbling.
There's a big one out
there, it's crazy humbling.
There's another one, can you
get the big one out there?
It's crazy humbling.
Here's the thing, I have no
idea really what to do with it.
I think it's kind of weird,
and the more I'm thinking about it,
it feels super douchey in some ways.
That's cool.
So here's what I'm doing.
I'm gonna sign these four amazing pieces.
These are amazing pieces.
I'm doing this video because I don't wanna
disrespect artists that gave me huge love.
But I think they have a better home,
I love my Macho Man, Randy Savage.
- The Macho Man, Randy Savage.
- I love my Carmelo thing.
I love my stuff.
But my own face in my own
office, listen I love myself,
but I can't have this shit around anymore.
So, shit about my pops, all day.
'Cause I gotta give that to him.
But just, this is the official video.
It's real simple, if you're gonna send me
a portrait of my thing, awesome,
and I'm gonna give you even more love
because I'm gonna sign them
and then give them away on social
and tag you so artists will
get love in the future.
But if you're making a portrait
with the hope that it's
gonna be in my office
or in my home and that gives you love,
I don't wanna make that
assumption anymore.
'Cause I don't need them, I mean,
I feel weird, I don't want portraits of me
in my fucking offices and my home.
You agree, right?
It's weird, like, alright, cool.
So here we go.
This one's awesome.
Sign away.
(writing)
This one's super well done.
- Here's one, a different color one.
- Nope, I'm good.
Cool, now here we go,
separate pieces of content.
So that's that, it's done,
and here's separate content.
Giving this away.
Dude, you can't talk to Drock.
He's an adjective now.
What is it, actually?
When people say that they
have a Drock, what is that?
What is that?
Guys, you don't even understand.
He won.
- [Man] A noun or an adjective?
- Yeah, what is it, Dan?
Who's the best in English.
- [Man] Uh, it's both.
- Is it both?
(mumbling)
Right, but it's really a noun, right?
- [Man] It's not a noun.
- [Gary] It's a noun.
- [Man] It's a videographer.
- [Man] Person, place, or thing.
- But you could be Drocking.
- Yeah, let them all
keep laughing, brother.
You won.
Literally.
- [Man] Wait a second, we know.
- You guys are all upset, right?
- [Man] Super upset.
- I get it.
Let's create a Lev.
(laughing)
What's the definition of that?
(mumbling)
So this is the (beeping) new video?
- [Man] Yeah.
- The number one mistake
that people are making
in life today and it's just
so unbelievably obvious,
is they're living life in the middle.
You know 99.9% of the people that
watch or listen to this content are living
in the middle.
They're hedging and making excuses
and justifying why they
are not 100% happy.
It's because, like every
other person out there
besides a few select people,
they are living in this middle ground.
And I just say fuck the middle.
And when I think about
how you win in business,
in entrepreneurship,
but most of all in life,
it's by understanding the
macro and micro
opportunities and executions.
If you really understand
how to break through,
how to be in that zone, how
to really, really, really
win the game, it comes down to a strategy
that looks like this.
Are you balancing your
ego with your humility?
Do you equally think that
you're the greatest of all time
and you can do it, and that also
you're a piece of shit and
nobody cares when you're gone?
Bye guys.
(light acoustic guitar)
I'll be right there.
Just gotta catch up on a couple things.
(mumbling)
(soft acoustic guitar)
Before you go, both are fine.
It's just the punchline.
It's actually binary.
You either talk about,
no question my biggest strength
is I'm narrow as fuck.
You know, as people that know who I am,
know that one of the
great things that people
bring up about me is that I see,
'cause I read everything,
"You're repetitive."
I'm like, good.
I'm like what do you want
me to do, make up shit?
(laughing)
I'm like I'm lucky that I use my
repetitive strategy on a changing world.
Voice is not repetitive, I promise you.
All my insights and ability is me
making voice come through my filter,
not me chasing voice.
(mumbling)
Right.
- I started a podcast and I just--
- You got it?
I'm the same forever.
- How do you grow your Spotify following.
'Cause he's had one
for about three months,
and he's trying to figure out how to grow.
- There's three ways to build shit.
One, collaborations.
Use somebody else's platform.
This video you're making right now,
you'll be able to leverage
my equity in some ways
for it to be more viewed, this and that.
So collaborations are an incredible,
you should be searching fishing hashtags,
and anybody pretty, cool,
with a lot of followers,
you need to be thinking about
how you can do something.
Cosigning, collaborations.
Number two is ads.
Guys ads are under-priced.
If you have the luxury of having money,
which you may or may not,
but Facebook and Twitter, excuse me,
Facebook and Instagram
ads are under-priced.
- So doing ads for the Spotify?
- 100%.
And number three, a complete commitment
to every other place you have attention.
If you go to my Instagram
profile right now,
my default URL is a link to my podcast
because right this second, I've decided
that's most important, the
signature of your email,
I will tell you, the
signature of your email
is one of the sneakiest real
estate that nobody uses.
So he should put his Spotify playlist,
if that's the most important,
the URL on your Twitter, your Instagram.
Using every other platform
to drive awareness to it.
Hug.
- Hug.
- So fun.
(clapping)
You enjoyed it?
(mumbling)
You're soaking it in, right?
Photo.
- [Man] Oh yeah, I need
to use the bathroom.
Yeah, that's a good idea.
Was.
- If you guys wanna get an
email and a reunion dinner?
(mellow music)